good afternoon everyone
uh today we are here to announce two
things first the relaxation of some of
the public health orders
and secondly more financial supports for
businesses
and the arts and culture sector
last friday you'll recall that minister
audrey gordon and as well as dr brent
russon announced that the current public
health orders
would be extended until tuesday february
8th to allow
for additional time to confirm the trend
in the covet 19 data and its impact on
the health care system
we are seeing some positive trends in
the data throughout the province
indicating that covid19 is starting to
stabilize in our province
as those trends continue i am pleased to
announce
as of february 8th we will begin to lift
some of the restrictions
these new measures will remain in effect
for the period of two weeks until
february 22nd
and new measures will take effect that
will include changes to
gatherings and private residences
retail restaurant license premises
capacity
and museum and art gallery capacity
as well as capacity for sporting events
i will now pass it over to dr russon who
will
fill us in on the details over to you
thank you thank you premiere good
afternoon brent russon manitoba's chief
provincial public health officer
last week
we announced an extension
of those public health orders
we had
been looking at modeling and looking at
trends
many of which were showing the
peak or pending peak
or or plateau at the time
we needed some more time to look at
those at those trends so we were
encouraged at the time but
weren't able to make a definitive call
as this week as has passed we see that
many of those indicators continue
to be stable or trending in the right
direction
and so we are getting a better
understanding of where we are in this in
this wave
so one of those factors that we look at
and one of the most important ones is
the the strain on health care system so
we look at hospital admissions
both hospital emissions and icu
admissions
those that are positive for covert 19 so
these have been very important
indicators
we've broken those down
in the past as
infectious and those considered
recovered or non-infectious at the time
but what we see is as we have widespread
transmission of omicron in the community
we see
very significant numbers of people who
are in hospital and test positive for
covid
for so for public health as we look at
our
need for restrictions and our path
forward it's really important for us to
understand
who's in hospital because of covet not
in hospital incidentally related to uh
to covet
and so it's uh
we know that
because omicron is so widespread we know
that every person admitted to hospitals
tested for oak run we're going to find
out
find people that were there for other
reasons but happen to test positive
record for covet so when we look at
hospitalizations when you look at
various ways of doing this through chart
audits we see that
about
60 percent of those that we report that
are admitted to hospital
are there for reasons other than covet
so those are people that are found to be
incidentally positive for coven so they
would be in hospital
for these reasons with or without covet
so we're looking about 40 of those that
we report in hospital um are related to
covid so this is uh still all those
people need care all those people that
are admitted still
put that strain on our health care
providers but it's important for us
public health looks at our the need for
restrictions who is there for uh kovit
and
and so certainly we see that
that split where um in in some
days up to about uh
one third of them were there for uh
covet and so it certainly helps inform
our modeling um
and our path forward so when we look at
icu admissions in the same manner they
that is
flipped over
we see that about two-thirds of people
or about 70 percent of people admitted
to icu are there for covet
so we see that that trend that the
majority of people who are covet
positive and i see are actually there
for a covet
but about one one third or there are
four reasons other than their colon
infection
um and so uh it's certainly relevant uh
to the way we look at our numbers um
when we look at those icu numbers again
it's very important uh to highlight the
importance of
vaccination uh we see
the the benefits of vaccination still
protecting against severe outcomes
and why we're really pushing our way
forward continues to be uh vaccinating
as many manitobans as we can so any
manitoban who's eligible for any of your
dos first second or third please get
that as soon as as possible
so it's certainly been been a while uh
since we've been able to consider easing
some of these public health restrictions
and so based on from what we're seeing
and things like hospital admissions and
case reports looking at absenteeism
rates from different sectors we do see
it's very likely that we've hit a peak
in in manitoba for case generation we
still see an icu some of that
slowing trend but still
upwards
so we can move cautiously at this point
we all know that the public health
measures were in place temporarily
they're always meant to be temporarily
and meant to be in place for only as
long and to the degree that they are
required
so the place we're at right now
we are recommending that new public
health orders take effect on tuesday
february 8th they'll be in effect for
two weeks
and so some of those details so
loosening restrictions on private
gatherings with more people allowed to
be together indoors and outdoors again
with differential rules based on vaccine
status
adjusting capacity limits at many public
places
so we're going to
maintain
the proof of vaccine requirements at the
places that they're required right now
we're going to maintain the 50
capacity of the nets where they are
right now what we're going to do is is
lift that maximum cap now we had these
many of these places capped at 250 now
we're going to remove that cap so it's
still going to be proof of vaccine
wherever that was required to pass still
be 50 capacity wherever that was
required in the past but removing that
cap of 250 people
we've had that
liquor sales to stop at 10 we're going
to extend that to
12 a.m
and as far as
sports
we will allow tournaments again for
indoor and outdoor sports and recreation
so over those uh two weeks we're going
to continue to monitor those trends
we know that the incubation period for
omicron is shorter and so our previous
duration of restrictions were based on a
much longer incubation period so we feel
that the two weeks is going to give us
a better picture of where we're at and
again consider a path
to a further loosening of the
restrictions we know these are only in
place temporarily
so we still maintain the proof of
vaccination requirements
um
but we continue to message the
manitobans the importance of receiving
those those vaccines as soon as you
become eligible so we know manitobans
have largely stepped up and followed
these rules
the majority vast majority manitobans
have done their part and gotten
vaccinated
and we all know that our path forward
must be one to continue to remove these
public health orders over time but in
obviously a cautious manner so um again
because of what manitobans have done the
actions manitobans have taken were once
again in this place to start losing
loosening our public health restrictions
so
thanks to all manitobans for all of your
hard work thanks to our health care
workers who have
given up so much during these
tough times and i'm going to pass it
back to the premiere
thank you very much dr russon and while
today's announcement will be welcome
news to
to many manitobans we recognize that
many businesses will still be impacted
by restrictions and will not be able to
operate to their full capacity
and that's why today we are also
announcing an expansion to the sector
support program to help manitoba
businesses and arts and culture
organizations through this challenging
time
the expansion will provide a second
payment
to businesses that have been previously
approved
and affected by public health orders in
place as of january 31st
expand eligibility under the program to
include event rentals
catering and photographers and extend
the pro the program intake period until
february 28th of this year
often described as the
first to close and last open we
recognize how difficult this time has
been for manitoba's vibrant arts and
culture sector
we are also allocating six million
dollars in new funding to the arts and
culture sustainability program to
support organizations in the sector that
are negatively impacted and affected by
the covet 19 public health order
restrictions
moving forward we will consult we
continue to consult with our public
health officials and our stakeholders as
we move through this pandemic and
continue to learn to live with this
virus
assuming the cobit 19 data from manitoba
continues along the path that is
projected we will for we will be in a
position hopefully to further relax
restrictions in the weeks and months
ahead
situation permitting and based
off of what the data is telling us at
the time we will be looking to remove a
significant amount of capacity limits
and restrictions
later this spring we hope to be in a
position of relaxing nearly all
restrictions and moving to
recommendations
i want to thank the over 87 percent
of manitobans 18 and older who have been
immunized with at least two doses and to
those who made the choice to protect the
nearly seventy thousand manitoba
children with a dose of the vaccine
to date our province has administered
over 2.7 million doses of the vaccine we
know that vaccines work i encourage
manitobans to get their third dose when
eligible to recharge your immunity to
covet 19.
getting your third dose of the vaccine
decreases your risk of needing icu care
by
139 times compared to someone who is
unvaccinated
i want to thank manitobans who have made
personal professional and financial
sacrifices and have done their part by
getting vaccinated and following the
fundamentals
i want to thank all of our frontline and
essential service workers for helping to
keep manitobans safe during this
pandemic
i am confident we will get through this
together
thank you to all of those manitobans
and we're now open for questions
premier we have this second highest
death rate in the country beautiful
right now we're averaging seven deaths a
day we had seven more today how do you
reconcile that with what you just
announced so um what i will say is that
obviously we we've been working with
public health to see and look at ways
that we can reduce the restrictions for
for those out there i think people are
are ready to get back to some some
normalcy as part of their life when it
comes to deaths and how they're reported
and in comparison to other provinces i
think we are looking and i've asked for
those numbers to see and those
comparisons across other provinces to
see are the are we comparing apples to
apples when it comes to this and so you
know we're obviously looking at that and
you know but to all those manitobans we
know this has been an incredibly
difficult time
we know that there has been a loss of of
of loved ones and and what i would say
is as well to manitobans you know that
we will get through this together it is
a very challenging time uh what we want
to do is ensure though that that you
know all manitobans will be able to have
the access to health care outside of
just cobit but but other other things as
well and we're obviously concerned about
those uh who are suffering from mental
health and and other issues out there
that we need to to focus on as well so
what do you say to the elderly uh
disabled
have immunocompromised manitobans who
are living in fear right now those are
the ones living in fear not general
society that they continue to see this
widespread omicron spread they continue
to see yes it is milder on an individual
basis but
you can even if you
if you talk to medical experts they say
we're underestimating covet deaths not
overestimating them as you just implied
what do you say to the families and
people who are disabled need a
compromise
what i would say first and foremost is
get vaccinated and make sure you've
gotten you're fully you're fully up to
to being vaccinated and you get the
extra dose of the third dose as well
i think that you know obviously these
are very very challenging times we don't
want people to be living in fear what we
want to do is is create an environment
here that uh that manitobans don't have
to live in fear
no to the extent that they're not then
then they should be but i believe that
most of them are but to their families
and loved ones who may not be um to to
those people
as well to encourage as many manitobans
to get vaccinated as possible the
vaccination messaging that you often go
to i appreciate that it's an important
message but i can ask you important
what do you have to say to vaccinated
people who are even compromised elderly
or disabled
i would say that we've had uh you know
restrictions in place to try and help um
you know with our hospital system i
think what we're seeing and i'll ask
brent to maybe comment on this in terms
of the number of people in in in
hospital the hospitalization numbers and
icu numbers that we've seen um you know
plateau
and i think that you know that's what
the restrictions were in place for as
we're starting to see the movement
towards the trend that we are i think
we're we're in a position to be able to
um to reduce those restrictions so
people can get back to
to living um living their lives
how much of this um
was demanded by businesses and i'm
talking specifically about the removal
of the 250-person crop
we're now going to see thousands of
people in large venues like the downtown
hockey arena and some casinos
potentially
is that not an additional risk and who
who asked for that cap to be lifted
so what i would say is is that um
certainly we are listening to those in
the business community you recall
three four weeks ago when we extended uh
the orders then and we extended it
another week
businesses are constantly reaching out
and giving us their perspective it's why
we've announced
further supports for some of those
businesses uh today uh with respect to
the orders uh that are before us today
i'll ask uh uh brent as well to to
comment on these these are things that
will work together that we work together
with with public health on
yeah and so i mean this follows our
typical approach to as when we were
loosening restrictions they we loosened
them in the reverse order of what we put
them on so we added these restrictions
late and you'll see and then those who
are the first now to to uh to be removed
so it's pretty uh standard approach that
we've had for our um cautious loosening
of restrictions over time and despite
the um you know all only evidence we've
seen is that if you're fully vaccinated
and you're not immunocompromised you the
chance of having very severe outcomes
for normal crime is quite low
but if you have a large crowd you will
get immunocompromised and people at risk
in that crowd
um are you comfortable with allowing
thousands of people
in an area even if they have to be fully
vaccinated
so i mean the the risk will never be
zero right so people who are living with
immune compromise with severe medical
conditions they've always been at risk
of many different things they've been at
risk every respiratory virus season as
well and and and uh if we see another
variant or
you know who knows what covert will do
next respirator of our season people who
are in those conditions are uh you know
are unfortunately at increased risk
so um
you know we've uh we have a lot of
measures still in place um so we do have
proof of vaccine requirements we have uh
masking that will be required uh but
yeah
we'll never have a a zero risk and then
some you know people will have to
consider some of their own risks as well
like
in
pre-pandemic times as well and we were
messaging this from the first wave of
the pandemic that if you're at increased
risk you need to reconsider how much
activities you uh you take place so even
before we had our first restrictions we
always had that high risk messaging as
well and and that that doesn't change
the reason manitoba hasn't gone with a
two household bubble for me like like
some other provinces have
to limit
that extended prolonged close indoor
contact that we see in household
gatherings
you know with the private gatherings i
think every jurisdiction has struggled
with what's the the right way to do this
right and it's a balance between one is
we want to limit contacts
but we need to do so through messaging
and through orders that are really
difficult to enforce and so what's the
best way to do that what's the clear way
of doing it do we say it's it's one
other bubble or two other bubbles what
does that bubble make up
or do we say a list a specific number
and so i think every every jurisdiction
has struggled that we've considered it
and
and i think we've taken different
approaches before i think it's just it's
really challenging to limit gatherings
in a private residence it's it's
important
but i think most of that relates to uh
you know to our messaging
to to do whatever you can to reduce
those uh
those gatherings and of course if you're
at increased risk of severe outcomes
then you need to
consider
reducing those even more
medical professionals have clapped back
at this notion of
with covet from cove and saying that a
lot of people yeah they're not there
primarily because of coving the copa is
a systemic illness and it causes a lot
and exacerbates other problems they also
say that there's a lot of people not
getting medical care right now
uh for all variety of reasons in the
health system because there is so many
cohort infections even the ones that do
classify a strict code
so i i know you're not from the shared
health system side here but
how what do you say to those doctors
uh that say that really we're still
really struggling in the health care
system
well i think there's i mean there's
certainly strained the health care
system for lots of reasons right as they
we've seen absenteeism we've seen the
strain over over two years there's
backlogs and things so so i mean there's
no no doubt there is that strain
do we use um
public health restrictions and remove
liberties solely based on on on that
strain if the strain isn't uh entirely
based on um
you know directly related to kova these
are kind of those balancing that the
challenge we have
so when you talk about the you know the
roughly sixty percent of the hospital
missions that we
um uh announce each day if they would be
there either way they're there
regardless of cover they just happen to
have covet it's certainly uh
not irrelevant certainly um it's
certainly relevant to how we um
consider moving forward with our
restrictions but no doubt is that is
that in any way saying
to depict that there isn't a strain on
the system but it's certainly relevant
to us that
you know 60 of the people there
would be there regardless of kovitz so
when we're looking at our restrictions
it's something we need to consider but
but absolutely uh the message is not to
say that there isn't a strain on the
health care system there's lots of
reasons for that
since you're appointed premier have you
gone to visit a hospital yourself in er
and i see you deceive yourself firsthand
trying to think if i have been in i
guess uh not since i've been premier no
i haven't
you know i i think it's out of respect
for um you know for the for the public
health orders and not wanting to
be in a position where i'm going in and
potentially uh infecting uh further i
think uh you know we're certainly in
discussions and i i rely on our minister
of health um and uh you know to to to
reach out and in those circumstances i
certainly am not opposed to going and
doing that it's basically been out of uh
an abundance of caution i would
say and we're in mid-december we had
about 381 million left in contingency
for covet-related things i know that
we've spent
22 on
on more business reports and i'm
guessing that's what you're matching
today so how much is left and why not
offer more to buy some more time yeah i
mean you know certainly um you know we
we offer these programs out there and
then we see what the what the uptake is
and we try and and uh and change them
accordingly to ensure that we can offer
more supports to as many manitobans
as we can and so what we have heard from
the business community from the chambers
and others that they that they
appreciate these supports uh to the
extent that there's more that we can do
i think we are doing more we are
reaching out now to the arts and culture
sector uh there may be some other
supports that are needed down the road
and we'll we'll gauge what those will be
and and um and uh take it from
what is there uh supply looking like for
the treatment for people who like the
monoclonal antibodies
yeah so that was uh we originally
received
roughly 1100 treatment courses
for pax levitt the oral antiviral and so
uh that is run through through shared
health so details on on the distribution
thus far should should go over to them
premier you've spoken up a
favor of vaccination your health
ministers called yourself a vaccine
ambassador but not everybody in your
caucus is acting like a vaccine
ambassador um i'm just wondering what
why is that and is there anything that
you can do to encourage your caucus to
be more vaccine
ambassadorial i don't know what the
proper term is but um
and and can you do that while
maintaining your support in those areas
of manitoba without alienating people in
winnipeg where most of the voters are
who will see that your government gets
reelected or not yeah i think what's
really important is that as a government
from day one once the vaccines were
released um uh you know we we we all
became or you know became ambassador
ambassadors within government to ensure
that
that as many manitobans got vaccinated
as possible uh to the extent that those
were in positions that you know were
saying some things contrary to that
they've been removed from those
positions we'll continue to have those
discussions in caucus i think it's very
important that caucus members have the
ability to represent their communities
we have a very diverse uh group of
individuals within our caucus they have
every right to represent their
constituencies those that
elected them and so we have those
discussions in caucus
thank you
a reminder to our reporters on the line
you will have one preliminary and one
follow-up question
up first this afternoon from city news
mike
good afternoon mike albanese from sydney
news uh my question is with all the
other loosenings of restrictions
um manitobans were able to look at
tangible stats and see that infections
were
on a downtrend that less people were
testing positive but with the current
restrictions to testing
we can't necessarily go and see how many
people are infected with the virus
a lot has to just go on the word of
public health officials
so dr rusen what can you tell manitobans
to make them more comfortable with the
fact that we are restricting well there
could still be a lot of virus in the
province
yeah well we know there is a lot of
virus right and so if we thought that
there was really no risk we would loosen
uh you know lift all the restrictions so
but we're not we're doing so in a very
cautious manner we presented modeling
last week
that shows where that that that peak
likely has been
and and the the path forward we redid
those models and they show us the same
thing this this
week that we've
very likely peaked in cases very likely
peaked in hospital emissions and are
either peaking or peaking soon regarding
admissions to icu
we look at
industries or sectors where there is
much more frequent testing and look at
absenteeism rates and their test rates
and we see those are all
showing us a peak
a week or two ago so there's a number of
indicators that we look at and we've
actually we presented those
the the modeling last week so you're
right things have have changed in the
way we we look at things because of the
testing approach but we still have a
number of indicators that we've
presented
for that answer um and with
the loosening of restrictions i know
we're not pulling all restrictions right
away but that does add variability do
our projected numbers our projected
cases our projected future outcome does
that not
go a little out the window when we start
adding these variables in as such as not
a cap of 250 people at a hockey game
could have tens of thousands
so it's why we you know continue to
message uh many
you know many of the factors you know
the fundamentals that we talk about why
we move things very cautiously to see
those effects
um and because you're right there is
some unpredictability when we when we
loosen certain measures um there's just
no way uh you know around that and
that's why we move cautiously and
evaluate the effect before we loosen
loosen further so
so i think again
these measures the public health
restrictions
they have negative effects as well
and so it's a matter of trying to to
find that balance which is which is
difficult but we feel based on the
modeling based on numbers we see this is
a
you know a pragmatic approach at this
point
from ctv winnipeg
jeff
oh hi uh hopefully you can hear me okay
i have trouble getting in
i'm just wondering dr roos and uh steve
has already asked about it but i take it
then with the lifting of that cap uh i
guess the jets can start having
if they want um uh higher capacity
limits
that's correct yeah so so venues such as
that sporting venues would be proof of
vaccine 50
capacity
masking
but there isn't a
cap on the on the total
okay and
both yourself in the premier have have
alluded to this but do you have a
timeline mapped out
you know after the next two weeks of
like other provinces have done like here
are some key dates
for when we're going to start to lose
other restrictions do you have kind of a
map
well certainly it's the thing that's
we've we're always discussing you know
the the short-term and medium and
long-term approaches to two things so we
don't have specific dates um and and
it's really challenging to come up with
the specific dates i think the message
is that
given where we are we are right now
if if we don't see anything unexpected
that we're looking at a restricting
restriction free manitoba by spring
from chvn
taylor
hi good afternoon i'm looking at the
health orders here and i see that for
places of worship there was quite a big
jump in how many people could attend
particularly without
proof of vaccination requirements can
you tell me a little bit more about
why you decided to do this
well
the uh so this is referring to the
um
yeah yeah so we have in places of
worship right now there's a 50 capacity
with no cap similar to other other
places they had a 25
capacity
um or you know 25 people although they
could get to
250 people if they cohorted so at this
measure we just loosened that and remove
the cohort requirements so it's 25
capacity or 250 whichever is lower but
not the need to to cohort
thanks and when you were making these
orders uh what did you hear from
religious leaders about this
yeah so you know with with public health
again we've
uh when we're loosening uh restrictions
we sort of just go in the
um you know the reverse order of them
coming in so this is a very moderate
modest uh loosening of these these
restrictions so public health hasn't
engaged with uh with religious leaders
at this point this is all about um a uh
cautious uh reopening when we're just
seeing our numbers starting to uh
plateau so we only felt a very cautious
reopening at this point was warranted
as well obviously we have a ministerial
working group that works very closely
with stakeholders in the community uh
including our faith-based community as
well so we're in constant contact with
them about about
the orders as well they reach out from
time to time we reach out to them and we
as we do with all stakeholders
from cjob
skyler
hi guys i know i asked you uh doctors
about this last week um just looking for
a little more context to some of these
hospitalization numbers i know we have
you know around 1500 medical beds in the
province maybe a couple hundred of them
were open last week if that
and of course now you're providing the
um you know with or because of type data
um but in terms of context where does
this
um you know compared to say like 2019
2018 when you know the hospitals were
filling up slightly because of the flu
obviously we're seeing way more deaths
because of covet 19 though just trying
to put that hospital situation into a
little more context for people
yeah and so i mean it's a good question
i i think i'm going to let
a shared health answer any details of
that
there's a lot of context that we have to
put in into place now
there's staffing issues right now that
we didn't have say in 2018
there are
issues on
you know delayed surgeries and and
things of that so
so it's not going to be essentially an
you know apples apples comparison on how
many people were admitted this time in
2018 compared to right now but the
details of that i'll
allow shared health to answer
okay i appreciate that
and just as my follow-up
you know we're looking at a potentially
a restriction-free manitoba in just two
or three months time
a lot of people may not be comfortable
with that but it is the beginning of
this clawing back of restriction kind of
ushering in an era where folks uh who
are immunocompromised are elderly are at
higher risk of some severe outcomes uh
need to take that responsibility into
their own hands and it's not being put
on the general public with broader
orders is that is that kind of the era
we're going into now well i mean i think
that's the that's our pre-pandemic era
right we we fo faced many
health challenges uh pre-pandemic we
unfortunately saw
many
deaths and severe outcomes every
respiratory virus season and the
majority of those occurred in
in unvaccinated
people and and as well people with many
underlying conditions those who are
older those who are immune compromised
so um you know when speaking about this
you can you never
never want to downplay the tragedy of
all of these events
but
but moving forward we do have to
find ways
out of these public health
restrictions because we know we're
always going to have
challenges
on you know some of the sickest
manitobans and so we definitely need to
find ways to protect them but it can't
be to
restrict the entire population forever
we've been at this for two years at some
point we have to find a way
out of that
from cdc radcho canada
god love
yes good afternoon uh
good afternoon i just want to raise a
concern about the trackers
uh with the premiere because um
we know the truckers are coming back
there was a legislative assistant who
was expelled because of his support to
the truckers
and now those properties are planning to
have a sitting in front of the winnipeg
legislature
hello yes we can hear you
yeah yeah so they're planning to have a
sitting in front of the winnipeg
legislature uh as from friday
until you relax respections what will
you do premiere please obviously we want
to ensure that everyone is is safe and
i know that
on the legislative grounds that
justice will ensure that uh there's
proper security in place to ensure the
the safety of of all of those
individuals on the on the ground i do
want to say that
you know to our truckers they have
allowed um us to be able to live through
this pandemic they have allowed the
supply chain to continue and and have
supplied us with our our food and our
clothing to wear and so i think we
should thank them as essential service
workers uh for what they do
um you know i did send out a letter uh
last week i guess uh just explaining you
know where i felt on on many of these
issues i am concerned about the mandate
that the prime minister put in place
because i am concerned about supply
chain issues and inflationary issues
we had a different approach in manitoba
when it came to
you know our provincial employees where
we looked at uh mandate you know either
get vaccinated or or get tested uh there
maybe is another way uh out of this to
ensure that we can continue that supply
chain which is absolutely critical for
not just manitobans but for canadians
yes but if i just have to follow up uh
somebody we're asking whether there is a
map we can follow after february 22nd
what will be what what is coming next
you could see the part of population
who is supporting the the the truckers
don't you think that some people are
tired of the restrictions
is there anything
are we going to lift
more restrictions in the next weeks or
the next month
well i'll start off with that uh and
then um hand it over to dr russon as
well for his comments i think he's
already sort of stated that this is a
cautious approach to to opening up
but obviously our end goal is to be able
to remove all health public health
restrictions to ensure that manitobans
can get back to living
normal lives so we i think we all have
the same end goal in mind as just that
we need to take perhaps a cautious
approach through this to ensure
you know that our health care system is
there for manitobans when they need it
from the brandon's son
karen
uh good afternoon everyone and uh thank
you for
for uh fielding these questions uh mine
is more about enforcement because we
have a company here
that was uh recently fined for uh uh
refusing uh the mass mandate i just
gotten
back from a meeting with them
and
um yeah just the general consensus from
them and allegedly from their customer
base is that they're tired of this
and but also looking at stats for fines
i see a lot more have been
ticketed for mass
refusal or failing to comply so is this
uh uptick in the last 30 days because
more people are refusing to wear their
masks or is there just more enforcement
you know i think it's
it could be a combination of both i
think people are generally getting you
know there's coveted fatigue out there i
think we've all seen it uh in our
various communities and and we we all
feel it
and so but obviously when it comes to uh
enforcement i know that uh you know we
have been tracking uh not just the
ticketing side of it but the warning
side of it as well uh for for
individuals uh as well so i know justice
is starting to to track those numbers as
well i think what's important here today
is that this is the start
of the the loosening of restrictions
we will be moving towards lifting all
restrictions at some point when it's
safe to do so and i think that what
we're asking for manitobans is just
for for patients through this um
we're everyone's tired of of the
restrictions everyone's tired of covid
but we need to ensure that we also take
that balanced approach where it comes to
um you know making sure that we are
protecting our hospital system but also
ensuring that manitobans can live their
lives
okay thank you for that and uh for my
follow-up just related to that a lot of
people have been
asking a lot of questions it's been more
than two years
a lot of money has been poured into
uh restrictions and funding for support
they would like to know why
there has hasn't there uh
exactly how much investment has been
made for
shoring up the health care system
yeah well you know every year we have uh
increased the budget for for health care
we have put special supports in place
through the covid pandemic as well and
and will uh continue to do so
obviously we have a challenge with
surgical and diagnostic backlogs we have
set up a task force to develop a plan to
get us through that
and we'll continue to work with them
closely on that i know that's top of
mind for manitobans so there will be
more investments that will be made over
over time in the province of manitoba
on friday our council of federation
is getting together and meeting about
this very issue with respect to the
canada health transfer uh the federal
government is going to have to come to
the table and work with us on this it's
not something that uh matt that uh
provinces can and territories can
shoulder alone we're all in this
together and we're gonna have to ensure
that we work together on it so i
appreciate
your uh your question very much
we now return to the news conference
theater questions in the
room up on gradle's question about the
truckers and the quad boy um
one of the things that the mp bergen
said in in the house was that
she she
said that the toppling of the statues
and the defacing of the statues on
canada here
she
said that was you know equivalent to
the protesters who were you know waving
nazi flags and
desecrating the the war memorial i'm
just wondering do you think that that is
a fair equivalency to compare what
happened on canada day here with statues
and angry you know protesters over the
deaths
uh
the graves that were found in
residential schools with um
the scenes of the symbols of hate that
we saw on display out here in front of
the building and in ottawa with the
convoy protest well we certainly
understand um you know with with
residential schools the hardships that
you know first nations have have uh have
have gone through and we want to work
with them through reconciliation and
ensure that we're helping them get
through this very difficult time
i don't condone any kind of
violent behavior anywhere at any time
and i don't think and i i believe at the
time there were some first nations
leaders who came out and said you know
that that we don't condone you know the
behavior of of of um you know what what
happened there and so you know i i would
i would agree with that uh but there's
no question that we need to work very
closely with indigenous communities to
help them heal through these very
difficult times and that is of course a
priority that i have mentioned in our
throne speech i mentioned it in
my inaugural address when i became
premier um reconciliation is is a
priority for our governments that wasn't
her question do you consider an
equivalent to topple a colonial figure
statue with showing a nazi flag and i'll
say it again i don't condone any violent
behavior anywhere i don't think it's
right
with respect
you see it's equivalent i do not condone
any violent behavior what's worse though
is one worse than the other do you think
that questions
i've answered that question a different
question dr normandam premier would you
uh have this plan to relax restrictions
on tuesday what response did you get
from perry gray and the various
specialty leads in the uh
health system
well we have frequent discussions we uh
uh dr gray is part of incident command
structure as well so we have various uh
discussions um
you know about about our approach about
their planning
and so we don't you know discuss
necessarily the the details of the
response and they're and they're varied
well it's not a big detail i'm asking
for did you get a thumbs up a neutral a
thumbs down like what was the general
tip no it's not as simple as that right
there's various restrictions at various
levels um there's uh you know we look at
various scenarios with the modeling
and and we take in a number of
considerations right so the their
responsibility is for
the acute care system and the capacity
within there we have a much broader
responsibility to the overall health and
manitobans and and and things so so it's
not as simple as just um
thumbs up or thumbs down
what happens a year from now if we look
at the we won't really get a real
picture of this till we see excess death
numbness through statscad in well into
2023 uh so
a year from now are you confident that
the approach you're taking right now is
the right approach knowing what that we
will see excess death numbers next year
well you know what we we
have to work with the uh with the
numbers in in front of us we know that
there are
um many aspects of of health
and and covet is one of them covet is a
for the last two years has been a strong
focus of the health care system of
public health
but it's not the only factor
related to health outcomes
so when we when we look at the risk of
covid
and talk about restrictions uh we really
can't do that thoroughly without looking
at a thoroughly what the um harms
related to the restrictions were
and so these are very challenging things
so i know that uh looking back in in
retrospect
is going to be a lot easier than having
to deal with it in in real time
with small businesses on the changes to
capacity because if everybody's still at
50 but you lift the 250 maximum that
really benefits big venues
and small videos really haven't changed
if you're a licensed premises or new car
restaurant that sort of thing so yeah
what has changed there is actually
moving from
10 o'clock to midnight to allow them to
be open longer as well we recognize
obviously that there are some hardships
with those those restaurants and and and
those tight in the bars those businesses
and uh obviously that's why we're
introducing further supports for them
today we recognize that these are
challenging times
thank you very much
did you forget about that
not disclosing the disposal of your
assets your housing minister in 2019 and
last week when we asked you know you had
declared them as assets and then after
they were sold there was no disclosure
or statement filed saying that you had
disposed of them you were housing mr at
the time and nato housing they were
taught there but there were plans to
devolve mental housing like can you
explain how there would be an oversight
like how you can forget about 30 million
dollars worth of assets being sold well
first of all mental housing has nothing
to do with this but secondly i did
disclose the disposition of those assets
uh so they were disposed of the you know
and they were declared in my conflict of
interest uh forms the next conflict of
interest form that came that came about
in my end and disclosed as well in my
meeting with the conflict of interest
commissioner what uh the issue is that i
didn't file the form to i think it is
within 30 days of the disposition of
those assets so to say that these assets
the disposition of these assets was not
disclosed is wrong it was it wasn't they
weren't it wasn't in the clerks it is it
is in my conflict of interest forms and
i it wasn't for two years no it was it
was absolutely um it was there because
as i filed my new conflict of interest
form those assets were no longer there
and i have my meeting with the conflict
of interest uh commissioner and why are
those not there because they've been
sold
right you know so
are you required to file a statement
saying that but that's the form two
which i said you know
there was no form two last week and your
office confirmed that well because once
it's already disclosed you can't go back
and file another form it's already
disclosed
it wasn't in your file on your office
yes it is disclosed i would suggest you
talk
secretary but it was an oversight i
believe you can send those questions to
you i have
well
there's it is disclosed so to say that
it hasn't been disclosed is wrong it was
an oversight and it would be disclosed
immediately
seriously just going to be on the way
more
dr
out for once again
okay no problem